I'm fascinated with chess and movies and
not just because I played chess in
middle school and competitively in high
school and college.
Chess is so interesting because of how
much meaning it can have in film,
whether it's through analogy,
metaphor,
or even a plot device.
Filmmakers love using the game to add to
their stories in a way no other game
can.
So let's play teach y'all.
If y'all want to lie,
man.
Nah,
come on right in the middle of the most
basic use of tests for an analogy,
it's usually to associate something with
patients or precision,
you know,
picked my punches to take him down.
Pendants state sets up the main
character as a tress player and he
references the game throughout film.
Firstly,
strategical position to pieces and when
the timing's right,
you strategy,
the next step is to use chest to show
somebody as smart.
And this is where filmmakers get clever
in 2001 a space Odyssey House
intelligence is established in his
ability to be humans in chess.
The importance of this scene is somewhat
lost on modern movie goers because
computers have been beating the best
chess players for the last 20 years,
but in 1968 it showed that how was not
only intelligent but very powerful.
If you look at the scene more closely,
it also foreshadows and important plot
point.
When this super computer tells the human
the better choice.
I'm sorry frank,
I think you missed it.
Waned to bishop.
Bishop takes.
Queen takes bishop night,
chest.
We see the computer disagreeing with the
human and making a better move for him,
showing very subtly that the computer
can conflict with and outsmart.
Hit this for shout as the plot quite
nicely and sorry Dave,
I'm afraid I can't do that.
How actually makes a mistake while
talking about the game,
his suggestion queen to Bishop three is
impossible in this position,
so how does have the force checkmate,
but he's declaring it incorrectly.
Now you could say this was either a
mistake on Kubrick's part or more.
Interestingly,
Kubrick is very subtly foreshadowing
house eventual breakdown.
The Duel Between Hal and frank.
Poole brings me to my third point.
Chess books nicely to represent a battle
between two people.
This can be as discreet or symbolic as
you like.
In Sherlock Holmes,
the montage of the chess game with an
actual conflict makes the idea of pretty
obvious.
It's a battle of wits,
but the events of the game almost always
stands for something more.
Chess is a very versatile game.
Pixar made short with the entire plot
revolving around a chest battle.
For example,
it's popular to use chest to show a
person sacrifice.
Maybe the most literal instance of this
is Harry Potter.
Sherlock goes for a queen sacrifice in
his game directly.
Mirroring Sherlock's plan to stop
moriarty
are winning.
Strategy sometimes sacrifice
to go one step further.
You can even let the chest pieces
themselves serve as metaphors for what's
happening in the movie.
Mag.
Needle fights with the powerful rook and
night pieces,
but professor x winds by sacrificing his
powerful pieces and using his bonds to
checkmate.
These moves reflect each player's
worldview.
Magneto.
Strong pieces represent him fighting
with mutans against the humans.
While professor x fights with the ponds
showing his desire to work with and
trust the humans.
This metaphor serves the movie nicely
because in chess,
upon can actually mutate into a night or
rook,
and this metaphor is further supported
when humans are referred to as ponds.
The exponent
interest,
the poem scuffs.
I think chess metaphors are most
powerful when they add to the story in
the people versus Oj Simpson.
Shapiro and Johnny Carson both have
chest sets in their offices during the
episode where they decide to make their
defense arguments center around race in
one shot.
The chess set is right in the
foreground.
Here we see an obvious choice to have
this chest set as the focal point in the
shot,
and I think it may mean something.
Of course I hesitate to read too far
into this,
but it's worth noting that chess is a
battle between black and white pieces
and in the context of this scene about
black versus white people.
That makes for a powerful visual and
adds to the idea that this trial was a
battle centering on race.
Maybe the perfect summation of all these
techniques comes from this chest scene
in the TV show.
The wire d essentially uses chest to
explain the drug trade,
the Brookside,
the stash.
The queen is the muscle and the king is
top dog.
He even goes so far as to naming the
pieces after actual people in their
gang.
What he ain't got no hustle,
but the rest of these motherfuckers on
the chain,
they got his back when they run so deep,
he really ain't gotta do shit.
But like your uncle?
Yeah,
like mom.
The Pantera
described as the soldiers and in reality
these kids are the soldiers in their
gang and so they naturally identify with
the ponds.
What's interesting is what Wallace.
His question is after he learns about
the pond,
they liked the front lines.
They'd be out in the field.
So how do you get to be the king and he
liked that.
See the Qing state of King.
Alright.
Anything stay who he is
as the ponds.
They always have to serve the king no
matter what.
Even if they get to the other side of
the board,
catch the other dudes king and trap it,
then you would all right,
but it will make it to the end.
I'm top dog now,
Yo,
it ain't like that
trust.
We learn about the drug trade and how
its hierarchy is that strict as the
rules of a board game.
No matter what.
These characters are trapped in their
roles with no way to escape.
They get sacrificed for the king and no
matter how they play,
they never get to be in charge ponds.
Man
in the game,
they get cab quick,
maybe out of the game early,
less they some smart ass poems
and movies that use to most games is one
dimensional.
Bingo is there to establish.
You're in a retirement home.
If you're playing dungeons and dragons,
the characters are stereotyped as nerdy,
but with chest there's almost always
more to analyze,
so get out there and make a move.
That's his majesty.
King is playing chess.
Chess.
Hey,
thanks for
slightly just a bit of a break from the
norm.
Just to break the monotony of all that
hard.